sie Posten bei Instagram als
Bundesregierung buberatz wird legal sie
bedienen sich der
Jugendsprache um ihren Gesetzesentwurf
unters Volk zu bringen wir werben gar
nicht sondern wir klären in der
Jugendsprache bubatz auf bubatz
beschädigt de geheren Kollegen in der
Regie woher kommt das ist das auf der
einer offiziellen Seite der
Bundesregierung höre gerade ja es wurde
verbreitet auf Instagram also es ist
wurde W nur das ist von der Seite an der
Seite der Bundesregierung also da steht
Bundesregierung normalerweise ist ja das
ich kann jetzt nur für unser
Bundesgesundheitsministerium sprechen
dass die Kampagne die wir machen
offizielle Account der Bundesregierung
höre ich gerade ja offiziell muss ich
prüfen aber ich kann jetzt nur für
unsere kampan müssen Sie nicht haben wir
schon für Sie gemacht ja alles gut aber
ich kann jetzt nur für die Kampagne
sprechen die ich selbst verantworte als
Bundesgesundheitsminister und wir haben
eine Kampagne gemacht die sich an junge
Leute wendet wo wir ganz genau
beschreiben in der Kampagne es ist legal
aber schädlich